>> It is my pleasure now to introduce
Cate-Cooney, who joins us from the University
of the Arts in Philadelphia, where
she is the coordinator of the TPS.
That's the Teaching with
Primary Sources Program.
Trained as both librarian and art
historian, Cate is comfortable
with the digital and physical realms.
She began her career by creating the digital
library for decorative arts and material culture
and later worked as an art
historian at Princeton University.
More recently Cate was headed of the printed
book and periodical collection at Winterthur,
where she taught connoisseurship of the
book using rare books as primary sources.
It is my sincere pleasure to welcome Cate.
>> Thank you so much, Cheryl, I
appreciate that kind introduction.
And I'm excited to be here this
evening talking to you all.
So, I'm here today to talk about analyzing
primary sources using Library of Congress tools.
Specifically we'll be considering
photography and we'll follow a guide created
by the University of the Arts called "Look Back.
See Further."
Studying photographs and drawing
connections between primary sources,
from the Library of Congress
and local collections.
My objectives for today are, to
familiarize you with the University
of the Arts online guide to photography.
To aid an understanding of
photographs as primary source material,
to get comfortable using Library of Congress
TPS, that's Teaching with Primary Sources,
analysis tool for photography, and
provide an introduction to Library
of Congress photography resources
available online.
So, I'm here to today to talk about "Look Back.
See Further."
Studying photographs and drawing connections
between primary sources from the Library
of Congress and local collections.
This guide is available of the University
of the Arts' website and a link to the URL
at the presentation so you
can be sure to have it.
The University of the Arts created this
guide to studying photographs meant for use
in the classroom or as an
inspiration for teaching.
The guide is intended to help users build visual
literacy skills using photography as the medium.
Visual literacy can be defined as making
meaning of images through analysis
and interpretation and using images effectively.
As you likely know, visual literacy is a
component covered in many educational standards,
including common core and other state standards.
For instance, English language arts
standards asks students to, I'm quoting,
"Integrate visual information with other
information in print and digital text," and to,
I'm going to quote again, "integrate and
evaluate content, presented in diverse media
and formats, including visually and
quantitatively, as well as in words."
So, we're going to focus on the first part
of our definition, making meaning of images
through analysis and interpretation.
The guide, "Look Back.
See Further.," can be used to help develop
the visual literacy skills of looking,
describing and evaluating content.
Using historical photographs in the
classroom is a great way to spark inquiry
and built visual literacy skills.
My goal today is to have us look at
photographs as sources in and of themselves,
rather than as illustrative material.
We're not going to take an idea and then
find photographs to illustrate that idea.
Instead, we're going to look at photographs and
see what questions and ideas those images raise.
So, here's what I'm on the
hook for this evening.
First I want to briefly give you the
context in which the guide was created.
Then I will discuss analyzing
photographs using the TPS analysis tool.
From there we will delve into looking at
three different types of images together.
A portrait, a street scene
and a recreational image.
Through analyzing these images
together we will see how looking at art
and specifically photography can lead to
discussions and investigation of larger issues.
Finally, I will do a brief
exploration of Library
of Congress photograph collections
of interest to educators.
So the University of the Arts joined the
Library of Congress's TPS educational consortium
with the goal of connecting,
teaching and learning to the arts
by using the arts visual arts,
music, literature, theater,
dance, architecture and on and on.
Students can investigate how humans use
creative activity to express celebrate,
explore and question their individual,
cultural and national identity in history.
Their place in the universe.
The arts provide a medium for exploring history,
science, language, mathematics, philosophy,
you get the idea, it goes on and on.
For the TPS program we developed week long
courses in which teachers would engage
with various media as primary sources.
And teachers find it engaging and exciting
to work with something that is both pervasive
in our popular culture as photography
is, but also an artistic medium
with a century and a half of history.
From this course we made a printed
guide to studying photographs for use
by teachers and students in the classroom.
This guide is available online as
a PDF, via the U Arts TPS website,
and it's in the teacher resources section.
So, again, we'll link to it at the end,
I just want you to be aware
that it is out there for you.
We wanted the guide to act as a model for
what teachers might do in their classroom,
including the idea of connecting the library's
online resources to resources available
to teachers in their local collections.
The guide connects primary sources from the
Library of Congress collections to objects
in the collection of the
Library Company of Philadelphia.
Our thought was that the guide could be printed
out and used in the classroom, or used online.
Teachers can work through the exercises
with students at a variety of grade levels
or they can look at the guide on
their own and use it as a model
for analyzing other images
that might be of interest.
So, let's jump right in to
looking at and analyzing images.
I'm going to model the method with this image
and then talk about the TPS analysis tool.
So, here's where I'm going to
ask you to start participating.
We're going to take a look at this image and
we start by describing exactly what we see.
So, take a good bit of time to look at
the image and describe what you see.
You don't have to try to be clever
or astute, you just have to look.
There's no training required for this, just
the time and the willingness to stick with it.
So, I'm going to set a timer for 30 seconds
so we can just sit and look at this image.
So, we just thinking about
what we see in the photograph.
Just describe what you see.
So, I see some people are looking
at it and wondering things about it.
They see people and trees,
mountain, maybe homes.
Some people are getting into the idea of
feelings, what they feel when they see it.
Great. And people are starting to ask questions.
What could it be?
So, did anything jump out at you?
What did you notice first?
If you are having a hard time getting going,
you can start with a few questions like,
"What objects, people or animals
do you see in the picture?"
Somebody saw tiny people and flat
buildings with a question mark.
I agree, flat buildings.
And I like that some people are
noticing what they don't see.
They don't see vehicles.
So, you might find that your observations
naturally lead into reflections,
such as wondering where this scene is.
A few people have said, "Are these barracks?"
Some people have wondered when it
was taken, is this an old photograph?
What are the buildings and
what are the people doing?
People are wondering, maybe you can wonder
where the photographer was positioned
and who the photograph was meant for.
So, what do you wonder about the photograph.
Oh, Faith, I'm excited that you started
wondering about the composition.
You noticed three different tiers.
Wondering what the photograph was for, Adrian
was wondering what could it have been for.
I love all these questions.
When is it, where is it, is the
ground covered in dust or in snow?
And why is there a lack of
structure to the right?
What else do we not see in this image?
And Amy wondered if it appears to
be an internment camp in the west,
why the environmental shot, why was it taken?
Isolated, but telephone poles.
Observations such as icy buildings and
a desolate landscape with mountains
in the background lead to concrete questions
such as, "Where was this picture taken?"
Or they might lead to reflections.
The observation< "The buildings are of
the same size and are arranged in rows,"
might make you reflect, "I wonder if
these are barracks or military buildings?"
Leading to the question,
"What are those buildings?"
It's best not to get caught up in the details
of whether something is an observation
or reflection or a question, instead,
let your curiosity lead and try to record
as many of your thoughts as possible.
Does it seem time has stopped and it
seems everything is very intentional.
I love your observations.
It's just fantastic.
So, the questions lead to ideas for research.
Some of the research can be simple, such
as looking at the cataloging record,
which is pictured and also linked here.
I intentionally did not give you
the cataloging information first,
since it might affect our observations to know
that this is an image of a
Japanese internment camp.
Or that it was taken by the famous photographer,
Ansel Adams for the US War Relocation Authority.
So, I've given you a little bit of a
chance to read this about this item.
I want to go back to the picture though,
because I think it's a little more
interesting than the cataloging record.
So, having no context for the image
allowed us to ask any question,
without feeling like we were supposed to
have known something about the picture.
However, now that we do have that information,
do you find that you have additional questions?
Now that you know more, what
more do you want to know?
Are there areas for further investigation?
Yes, is that why the composition is so good?
I think Ansel Adams definitely --
his professionalism is showing
in this image, isn't it.
Questions of point of view, what is included
and excluded are especially
important in photography.
Oh, I'm starting to see some of the things
you're wondering about and I want to read these.
People are wondering if the camp still exists,
how much does a professional artistic technique
affect the message or lens on the image?
People want to know how big the camp
was, what was the artist message
with composing this shot that
emphasized the mountains?
Is it propaganda?
So, these questions and questions
of point of view, what's included
and excluded are especially
important in photography.
A medium which can be manipulated.
For instance, I see that somebody's noticed
that there are no fences around the camp.
You might wonder, if this is an
internment camp, why don't we see fences,
why don't we see barbed wire, armed guards?
Where was Adams when he was
taking this picture, right?
Where's he situated?
Well, a little research informed me that
Adams was instructed not to include things
like the fences, the barbed wire, the
armed guards in his photos of the camp.
Remember he was asked by the
US War of Relocation Authority
to take these pictures and
they wanted those left out.
Adams actually took the photograph
from the top of a guard tower,
which not only gave a panoramic view
of the camp, but ensured the trappings
of confinement would be excluded from the image.
How an image was made is also an important
consideration when looking at photography.
The technology itself affects
the resulting image.
So, the extraordinary depth of field in
this image, the fact that the tiny details
in the middle and the background
are crisp and focused is due
to the large format camera that Adams used.
The Library of Congress created a tool to
help students record their observations
and capture their reflections and
questions about a primary source.
Here it is, it's called the
TPS Analysis Tool and remember,
TPS is Teaching with Primary Sources.
So, here's a TPS analysis tool filled
out for an Ansel Adams example.
You see that you can select the
format of your primary source.
I selected photographs and prints, and
I recorded some of our observations.
Lots of buildings and roads, mountains in
the background, tiny people in the road,
bushes and trees, black and white, etc., etc.
So, there are also reflections, questions,
where is it, who took the photo, why was it
taken and ideas for further investigation.
The tool is available on the Library of
Congress website in the teacher section.
You can't print out blank forms or you can fill
it out online or download and email the form.
Here we see the teacher's guide to
analyzing photographs and prints.
As you can see, students are encouraged
to go back and forth between the columns.
There's no correct order.
As we observe details and identified what we saw
in the image we naturally reflected and wondered
about what we were seeing and
then generated questions about it.
But it's a circular process,
it can go back and forth.
It's not necessarily linear.
So, let's give this image a try.
Here's a photographic portrait.
Again, what do you see?
I'm going to set the timer again
for 30 seconds so we can look
and then let's describe it together.
Well, this is a good image
for noticing fine details.
People are saying that he looks stern,
he's formally dressed, the frame is worn,
he's wearing some sort of a tie or an ascot,
he's very well dressed and looks severe.
What do you notice about his expression?
Oh, somebody noticed the Kodak EPY,
which might date the photography.
I will note up at the very top of the image
you see in yellow it says, "Kodak EPY."
That's actually an artifact of photographing
the photograph and digitizing that,
rather than the image itself, which
is just within that brown frame.
A very stern look, perhaps one you might give
your children when they are being difficult.
Stern but possibly smiling around the eyes.
And a few of you noticed his clothing.
What do you notice about his clothing?
Do you feel like it provides any clues to
his personality or his social standing?
So, his clothing a lot of people are saying that
maybe he's wealthy or of a high social standing.
It looks very formal.
So far nobody says it looks casual, so I almost
don't feel like I should ask this question, is,
"Whether you would describe
it as formal or casual?"
But how do you think he was
trying to present himself?
What do you wonder about who took the
photograph or why the photograph was taken?
Long skinny fingers, doesn't
look like a tough worker.
I'm loving your descriptions.
It's really interesting.
So, the picture is a portrait.
It's a portrait of John Sachse.
It was taken by the photographer,
Robert Cornelius in 1841 or 1842.
It's a type of photo called a daguerreotype.
A daguerreotype is a unique photographic image
on a polished sheet of silver-plated copper.
The process was invented in France in
1839 and alter that year Cornelius set
up the camera he built himself
and made what is now thought
to be the earliest existing American portrait
photograph, which is shown here on the screen.
Cornelius was an amateur chemist who
experimented with photography trying
to make the daguerreotype process fast
enough to be used for portraiture.
These images require a long exposure time,
during which the subject must
remain as still as possible.
So, several of you noted that he
looked almost pained in that picture.
He had to sit still for a really long time.
So, as you can see, he certainly
perfected the technique
by the time he photographed
Sachsen in 1841 or so.
This self-portrait that you see on the screen
is from the Library of Congress collection
and we discuss it in our guide, "Look Back.
See Further."
There are so many questions to
consider with these portraits.
You can think about how you would compare
Cornelius's self-portrait or his portrait
of Sachse to the selfies and pictures
of friends that we take today.
Somebody mentioned earlier
that the picture looked
like it might have been small,
and, in fact, it was.
It makes you wonder, who is the audience
for a single 2 1/2" by 3 1/4" daguerreotype?
Well, who's the audience for a selfie
that somebody posts on Instagram?
Cornelius opened Philadelphia's
first daguerreotype studio.
He took portraits of people who
paid $% for a small daguerreotype.
Just the right size to hold in one's hand.
The images were slow to make
and expensive to purchase.
A person may have only ever had one
portrait done in her entire life.
How would you present yourself if you were
only being photographed once in your life?
Somebody asked, "Was it expensive?"
It was expensive.
$5 doesn't seem like much now,
but it certainly was then.
So, portraitures a really good way
to engage students with looking
at photography for the first time.
Portraits are familiar.
Most of us have many portrait photographs
of ourselves or our loved ones,
but historical portrait photographs are also
strange, because the photographic process,
fashion and social cues were all
quite different 175 years ago.
Using portrait photographs is a great way to get
students started with talking about identity.
Who they are and how to understand others.
I'm going to pause a second here to
see how you would present yourself
if you were being photographed
only once in your life.
Teresa said she'd be smiling
and Jennifer would be young.
I think I'd be both.
So, now that we've gotten started with
a portrait, we can go ahead and move
onto something a little less
immediately accessible.
And that is a street scene.
So, once again, I'd like to ask you,
"What do you see in this picture?"
Again I'm going to set the timer for 30 seconds
so you can have a look and start thinking.
You guys are pros at this, you've
already started jumping right
in with all these great questions
and observations about bare trees,
leading you to wonder what the
season was and where this could be.
Maybe somebody sitting on a car or
sitting on a car without a horse,
is this a cemetery, could be fall or winter.
Oh, yeah the shadows could tell
you what time of day it is.
So, building on your knowledge from the
portrait, could you describe the photograph?
Are there any clues in the color, tone,
surface marks, that give you ideas
as to how the image was made
or how old it might be?
The clothing could date the
photograph, somebody said.
And somebody's noticed maybe this is another
daguerreotype, maybe that's some silvering.
Noticing the change in tone,
it's kind of a sepia color.
Well, the title tells us that this is the
entrance to Independence Square, Philadelphia.
It was taken between 1840 and 1856,
so we really don't know exactly when,
but we have a span of dates.
So, looking at the image, what do you
wonder about the place, what do you wonder
about the connection of the people in the image
to the place where they were photographed?
Since we know a little bit about daguerreotypes
now, we know that it was made at a time
when photography was neither common, nor easy.
We can assume that the choices of location,
subjects and their poses are all deliberate.
And people are wondering why there's a gate.
If this is Independence Square,
why is there a gate?
Was the gate locked?
Well, here's what I believe
is the same place today.
A screen shot from Google Street View.
Google Street View is a fun way to compare
historic images with the present day.
It's an exercise that can be done
with students of many different ages.
And it's really fun and sometimes it's
easy and sometimes it's really hard,
because buildings change
and street layouts change.
This one was a little hard to nail
down, but I think I got the right place.
And Teresa's been there, wonderful.
So, I'm going to go ahead and
move on to our final photograph.
For our final photograph we'll look at something
quitter different from the ones we have seen.
So, what do you see?
I'm going to set my timer
again while we all look.
So, this one is already bringing
up questions about technology.
You all noticed -- it seems like
you've all noticed right away
that you have two images side by side.
Are there any other things you notice?
You notice that the woman is diving and
that there's a city in the background.
That's a good eye.
The same picture's been taken,
but from different time stamps
or angels, is what Patricia has said.
So, we did, we all noticed that there
are these two images side by side.
It's a stereograph card.
Stereographs are two nearly identical
images, mounted side by side on a card.
When looked at through a special
viewer and you can see the woman
in these two images is looking
through a special viewer.
This image takes on a three dimensional quality.
Viewing stereographs became
a very popular entertainment
for middle class people during
the Victorian era.
We know that this stereograph
card dates from around 1892.
Sporting activities were becoming
increasingly popular in this period.
Women were taking part in recreations
like archery, bicycling and swimming.
Women were appearing in public in ways
that were not previously accepted.
During this period we see more and more
images of the new woman on stereograph cards.
A simple entertainment can have a much
deeper meaning if we delve into it.
It is, it's kind of like a view master toy.
So I only have a brief time left, I would
love to just talk about stereograph cards
and all your great observations, because
you've been so engaged, it's really fun.
But, I should talk about the
vast photographic resources
that are available at the Library of Congress.
There are more than a million items from the
prints and photograph division available online,
so let's just talk about a few
related to today's presentation.
I would like to encourage you to explore the
library's prints and photograph division.
It is a treasure trove.
Our first image way back several
-- what, 40 minutes ago almost --
came from the collection
of Ansel Adams' photographs
of Japanese American internment at Manzanar.
This is a collection of about 200 images, mostly
portraits, that Adams took at the camp in 1943.
In addition to the portraits the
collection documents daily life at the camp.
Adams himself donated the collection to
the library, stating that the collection
of his work was to show how the Japanese
Americans at the camp overcame what he saw
as a great injustice, by building themselves a
meaningful life, despite losing their property
and livelihoods and being
isolated in a remote environment.
An excellent essay accompanies this
collection and can be accessed in that articles
and essay tab under the collection title.
And here's the book that Adams
published with these images.
It's called born free and equal.
And it's available in digital
form on the library site.
And I just wanted to show another
example from the collection.
Here are three school children.
The Robert Cornelius portrait
of Sachse, his self-portrait,
and the Philadelphia street scene are all in
the library's collection of daguerreotypes.
Most of the 700 or so items in the
daguerreotype collection are portraits,
such as this one of a man named Edward Jay Roy,
but as we saw, there are also some street scenes
and landscapes, as well as
reproductions of works of art.
Diving Woman came from the library's
collection of stereograph cards.
We've already discussed the
technology of the stereo card.
The fact that the library had more than
52,000 of these cards is a testament
to their popularity as an entertainment.
More than 8000 are available in digital
form and may be searched online.
Stereo cards were first produced in the
United States in 1851 and remained popular
through the earliest part of the 20th century.
They are excellent for studying popular
culture, historic scenes and places,
including things like events, such as
the San Francisco earthquake of 1906.
The library has a fun feature
called, "Mystery Stereographs,"
where they post a stereograph card for
which they cannot find complete information
and they ask us to help find a -- help solve
the mystery of who and what, when, or why.
This is the one that I took a
screen shot of a few weeks ago.
So, I think there's a new one up by now.
You can find photographs by searching
the library catalogue at loc.gov
or you can check out the library's Flickr page.
I'd like to thank you for your time
and attention today and please do check
out our guide to studying
photographs, "Look Back.
See Further.," which is hyperlinked here.
In it you will find three of the exercises
we did today with additional information
about each image, as well as
analysis of two more types of images.
I encourage you to have a look at the
guide, download it, print it and I wanted
to thank you also for your great comments,
it was really really fun to work with you.
>> Cate, thank you so much.
This is Cheryl Latterly [assumed spelling]
again, from the Library of Congress.
And I want to say that the conversations were
rich and lively and you seemed very very engaged
and I know I'm leaving with lots to think
about, so thank you for participating and thanks
to Cate for facilitating
such a good conversation.